Yeah.
Hey, what's going on? Is Bill Burn?
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and
[inaudible] just checking
in. Are you? Hey,
what's going on?
How's your week going?
Is it going good?
That is good.
You're keeping your head
above the fucking water. Um,
I'm having, it's a great, we,
I'm having the best of times.
I'm having the worst of times.
My fucking phone, my phone.
I don't know what's going on with it.
Nothing on it says it needs to be updated,
but it keeps saying that it needs to be
updated and now it won't connect to my,
my wireless cell phone carrier.
Sometimes it does.
Sometimes it doesn't. Oh, I'll look
at it. Oh, what is it doing now?
What is it doing now?
I can't tell if I fucking fixed it or not.
You know what? These fucking assholes
at apple do these fucking assholes.
Do you remember back in the day you could
opt out and not update your phone and
you could keep it forever? So
they're like, oh God forbid God. God,
that did one fucking nickel.
Those cheap fucking money grubbing
corporate cons. God for fucking bid.
One fucking nickel rolls out the
window that they feel belongs,
rightfully belongs in their pocket.
So now where do they do now?
You can't opt out of the update.
Now you have to update the phone and it's
all designed to fill up your old phone,
right? So then you fucking bring
the fucking thing in. Yeah.
And then you got to get
the one that like take,
takes a picture of your
face or whatever it does.
And then now we will take
your old phone until what?
Give it to the poor bastard in Philippines
that had a fucking put the thing
together.
Here's your reward.
Yeah.
For working in our fucking factory
for 20 fucking hours a day,
making these new iPhone 19 so we're
going to give you the old iPhone seven
way to go there, buddy. You know, and
then, and if you don't do that, yeah,
just fucking throw the things out.
And they end up in the fucking ocean.
And like somehow these people
aren't the fucking problem.
These people are let, let's go to
the other fucking side of the world.
Blow $1 billion a fucking month,
fighting 3,500 jerk offs
on a fucking jungle gym.
But these cunts who are polluting the
ocean have poisoned the fucking food
supply.
Turned it into God knows what.
You got nine year olds walking around
with fucking mustaches cause there's so
much fucking human growth hormone,
whatever the fuck they're putting in the
Goddamn Shit, right? And not the problem.
Really.
That's all fucking isis has to do.
Just spend 300 grand on a
fucking chicken Parmesan plate to
okay.
Help finance your fucking campaign.
Then they're in the clear that's
all they need to do. Sorry.
That's how far I take it with a
fucking update on my phone. Hey Bill,
why don't you just give in man,
everybody's gonna do it, man.
Go get the fucking phone with you
if you have your face recognition.
I'm in plain like this.
Mental tennis.
I keep threatening to leave
apple like fuck these guys.
Cause my laptop's almost
full. My, uh, my cell phone.
I don't know what's going on with it.
It seems to be working when I'm
around my house, but it's Hilarious,
right when I need the fucking thing,
it shuts off,
which makes me feel like the computer
content in it is looking at my calendar.
Oh, he needs, he needs to do a radio
tour. You know the phones just like, God,
I think we'll just shut down now.
Last night I had to call in the fucking
sports gambling podcast was Sean Green
and Ryan Kramer.
All right.
Which still be playing
on this show tonight.
Actually, no, I'm sorry. I'll be
playing it later on in my podcast.
Right before the,
the throwback episode we'll be playing
and after I'm done ranting about my
fucking phone,
um,
you know, I'm actually
considering leaving, but then,
you know, somebody said,
well apple actually pushed back against
the FBI, you know, on the privacy thing.
And it's just like, what?
Then they're also doing all
this fucking creepy shit. I,
you know, the worst fucking move I
ever made was getting a smartphone.
All right. I should have stayed with the
flip phone, but now I got the smartphone.
You know, it's like you're riding first
class and I, you have to go back to coach.
But I'm really considering considering,
you know,
maybe I'll get like a second phone for
all these fucking radio tour things that
I have to do that I love doing.
Calling in all these great shows
that it helped me promote my shows.
Maybe I'll just do that because I'd never
heard of anybody talking about their
day flip phone fucking crapping out.
Really. Does that make me a hipster?
If I get one of those?
Um, I dunno, you know,
Goddamn well it'd be down the apple store.
Here's the iPhone 10 show us your face.
Okay.
Yeah,
I'm trusting you won't do
anything elicit with that.
Everything's above board even though
you're not concerned with polluting the
fucking environment. I mean, to be honest
with you, like with these corporations,
like when, when, when does it
fucking stop these fucking bankers?
When does it fucking stop?
It's unreal and you can't say anything.
You fucking say anything. They
label you as socialist. It's like,
I'm not the one pollutant, the fucking
oceans. I'm fine with this phone.
How much better does
the camera have to be?
We're going to be able to count the
pores on my fucking relatives faces.
It's fine. You did a bang
up job. How about this?
How about you own the phone and
I'll fucking rented from you.
Okay.
Every read much more forward.
Everything must be a little bit better.
Okay.
Someone shows up to work.
They have the better phone.
Yeah.
It makes the others feel less than,
um,
anyways, so that I got, I got rid of the
worst part of week, which is that shit.
And of course I have to um,
fly out early tomorrow morning to go
to Saginaw, Michigan, which by the way,
I just found out from some
of my relatives than, uh,
my great grandparents had a house
out there like a hundred years ago.
So I have the address. No,
I won't be saying it. Yes,
I put it in my phone.
Yes.
Steve jobs from beyond the grave is
already fucking in fucking drone with his
spirit hovering over it so
they can capture me there.
There's some fucking face recognition
about the top of my head, whatever the,
whatever the fuck those creeps
are trying to do over there.
Like some of these people,
they literally have to put nets outside
their factory to prevent people from
leaping to their fucking deaths.
And for some reason they're not a problem.
It's not a fucking problem. Look, the
other fucking way, I don't get it. Um,
um, anyways, plowing ahead. So
I'll be in Saginaw, Michigan,
which I've never performed there,
so I'm very excited.
MMM.
To go there. Uh, my hour,
I got an hour and a half right now and
it is more than ready to be recorded.
So freckles got to figure out when
he's going to do is next special.
Cause last night I did a private Gig,
um,
for this Jewish community and ed and um,
but I had such a great time.
I was only supposed to do a half hour.
I felt like I was on stage for 20 minutes
and I looked down and I had done an
hour. So then the psych, right. This
is, uh, it's time, it's time to go.
But I had such a good time at
that fucking Gig, you know,
usually I don't like to perform in front
of like all like one group of people,
you know?
Yeah.
Cause everybody has the same perspective
and then it kind of closes down what
you can talk about. Um, but this crowd
last night was day. What they were, uh,
they anywhere they were amazing. You
know, his buddy of mine book the thing
and uh, we were backstage
and he had cigars and shit.
It was just like, what am I,
one of my favorite gigs
of the year. And, um,
I gotta be honest with you,
like I've, I've really fucking,
I'm learning how not to get in
arguments with people, you know,
cause we were just talking about
all this shit and then he brings up,
what do you think about Israel?
I'm like, oh, I get sick, dude.
I'm not gonna fucking
get into this with you.
What to think about it. I mean, what
do you want foot? It's like everything.
It starts with a good idea how it's
executed. Is that the best idea? I don't,
I don't know. I think there's
mistakes made up both sides.
And then it's literally like trying to
talk to a sports fan when they can't see
anything that their team does wrong.
So he started to get into it and
I was just like, you know what?
Fair enough. What do you think
about the red sox Astros? Like,
I'm not going to get into
this fucking debate with you.
You know?
Um,
and we avoided this huge fucking
debate on something that I have.
I'm not really well read on,
but the old me,
I would dove right in both fucking feet,
you know what I mean?
Comparing this country
with the native Americans,
I was prepared to do all of that,
none of which I'm well read on.
And I was just like,
you know what pill?
Why don't you just shut the fuck up
and smoke your cigar? So I just said,
you know, fair enough. Why am I
going to get this guy all stirred up,
speaking in third of a fact that I
overheard and a fucking airport and let it
go. And it was great. You know,
here's another great part of my week.
The fucking Red Sox beat the New York
Yankees and another playoff series that's
two in a row. You know,
we're on a hell of a run.
I think they beat us like while I guess
not the place, but you know what I mean.
They beat us up.
I think this is our century.
MMM.
All right. Here's the deal. You know,
but you know me, I don't fucking rub it.
All right.
I want to congratulate the Yankees on a,
on a hundred wins season and the direction
that they are going in because those
guys, they're going to be a
force and asthma for Yankee fans.
As much as this one hurt.
Um,
it's going to make like
those your team feeling,
that feeling of fucking losing,
they're not gonna want to feel it again.
And I already thought that they
were, they were playing great. Um,
and I'm not going to sit there and act
like I'm a GM and I know what PC you need.
Um, oh, now what to say. Now look at, look
at, look at my fucking now my computer.
One fucking start back up. All
right, here we go. Um, but, uh,
it was just a great series and,
um,
being a,
I dunno,
it's just grateful baseball when
those two teams come together and uh,
yeah. And I realized when I was watching
it that I don't hate the Yankees.
I mean it, how can you hate the greatest
fucking organization, 27 championships?
You can't get mad at that, you know,
and I don't even hate their fans.
It's just that small segment
of fan that if they won,
you know,
the amount of shit that they would've
talked would have been just like,
I'm like,
did you see like in the eighth inning,
right when we loaded up the basis in the
clincher and that stud came out for the
Yankees and he just pitched him
out of the situation or whatever.
And you're out of the situation. He
put himself in, I can't even remember.
It was a fucking blur.
And when he struck out that
dude with the bases loaded,
when he went to the Dugout,
those two fat fucks like
ringing up the last batter act.
Like those are the more on
say like, Oh damn. Oh Damn.
Yeah.
Those fucking mouth breathing morons.
Those are the ones straight across the
board in sports that patriots have those
fans, red sox have of, you know,
I'm not saying all of their fans,
they just have those fucking
people and they're the ones that,
um, they're the ones that
ruin it. You know, like the,
those are the ones that like if I actually
sat across from them when they got
over the fact that I was a red sox fan
and I wanted to talk to the rivalry,
I could never get past like a,
a bug. They bufo a Joe, his fucking stupid
like those people. It's
just like, all right.
So that was the only time I felt
hate in that series. What is,
when I saw those fucking idiots, and
I gotta be honest with you, dude,
uh,
this is embarrassing to say,
but the level of mouth breather when
they painted the crowd in Yankee Stadium
and at Fenway Park is just unparalleled.
It's in Philly too. I don't know
what it is. You know what I mean?
It goes down south. He got the southern
bell, yet the fucking good old boy.
You go out Midwest, you get those people
dress like Pete Carroll, you know,
just like how does a person
in their 20s dress like that?
Then you go out to the west coast,
they got their own vibe, you know,
and, but like I'm telling the east coast
like I gotta I gotta be honest with you.
Like we,
we have corner.
It's so weird cause you have some of
the smartest fucking people like Boston,
New York have a real similarity there
where both cities are re really ride on
the coattails of the amount of
smart people that moved to the city.
You know, Boston has, they have
high avid, they got fucking MIT,
they got bu, Emerson College, all
these places where all these smart,
talented kids come into the city
juxtaposed to the locals
in New York.
You got all that bridge and tunnel,
all these fucking people that
move into Manhattan, you know,
and really make it what it is.
And then he's dead dead.
He's dodged.
Oh do these fucking morons sweatpants,
Hoodie,
fucking tad stake Eaton fucking mouth.
Breathing mouth breathing fucking morons.
Um,
I got a kick out of that and I am one
of those fucking morons, by the way.
I'm not,
I'm not trying to be a Goddamn elitists
tier now that he moved out the fucking
phony ass Hollywood. I'm not looking
down my adorable little nose at,
you know, I am not. I was that guy.
I was that guy out in
the fucking outfield.
We wanted to make his section laugh
who was loud fucking drunk. I did that.
Plenty of games. It's gotta be some sort
of security footage out there of it.
Um, anyways, so sale comes in
the eighth inning and just,
I mean for a red sox fan
versus the Yankees, I mean,
I don't think you ever get over fucking
2003 the seventh and eighth fucking
innings and then it's just
like those innings, you know,
all the way back to Bucky
makes you fucking nervous and
okay,
he fucking just cruise right through
the eighth inning and like, oh my God,
we have a three run fucking lead.
And then I see Cam roll up and I'm
just like, don't put that guy in.
How about the fucking guy in the seventh
inning with the Bob Stanley Torso.
I don't know anybody's fucking
names anymore. I've got a kid,
I don't have time to figure this shit out.
I was going like, oh this motherfucker,
look at this. How is he
decide to shape with all the,
all the exercise videos out there,
all the fucking nutritionist all
look at this guy. Look at this guy.
He should have that fucking cop utility
belt on when he's out there pitching.
So anyways,
he does great fucking sales.
Shuts them down.
Then Kimberly comes out and what it
proceeds to load the fucking basis.
And I'm telling you,
I thought I was past it.
I kept telling him all I wanted
to see him do was when it wants.
They've won it three times.
Come on down from three three Oh you know,
all three took to win.
You know,
biggest comeback in baseball
history. I'm good. I,
I really thought that. I
believe that. And then I just,
the night that he came and I
could not stay in the room,
I want to apologize
to Kimbro for all this shit I
said about him in that Anagen
uh,
God,
I was out in the kitchen between pitches
and I would run and I poked my head in
another ball and have you then I would
just Tourette's walking out and my
daughter was asleep. So I'm like
whispering, she's fucking pushed off.
Fucking strike you fucking cunt, right?
You fucking red baron and fucking God.
What the fuck would Julie
fucking style in there?
Okay.
So anyways,
when that's they,
they then it's forwarded to, then it's
fucking 40th. He, it's a fucking bad.
Or to make it four to two hits,
a batter with the bases loaded,
walks in a fucking run basically,
or whatever.
He hits a bad run in Dennis sac fly.
Now it's four to fucking three.
Those fat mouth breathers, I can see a
fucking freaking out the jelly bodies.
And then there's a slow dribbler
down to the third baseline.
And I'm like, oh my God, this
going to be an infield hit.
And then he calls the fucking dude
out and I did the most embarrassing
celebration dance and um,
dental,
like it's under review. And I'm
like, oh my God, is this game tied?
Are they going to tell me that
this fucking game is tied?
And then of course they came back and
said that it wasn't, but Jesus Christ,
I can't believe how much I still care.
It's fucking ridiculous.
So then I texted a buddy of mine from
back in the day and I was just like,
did you ever think you'd see the red sox
drink champagne in the fucking Yankee
stadiums you twice in your life?
This is unbelievable.
And then he wrote back to me,
it's dead. It's really dead.
All that fucking Bucky dent shit is dead.
And I laugh.
And I was like, yeah, but guys like you
and me are still going to have, you know,
post traumatic stress disorder from
all of those times where it wasn't.
And he was like laughing going, yeah. So
I think there's like this weird sort of,
um,
it's schism the word between
red sox fans right now.
There's the people that lived through it
and the people that don't know anything
but what's going on right now.
And I like being around those people.
The second ones,
the ones who are just thinking positive,
cause I actually found
myself saying positive shit.
He's going to strike this palm out. Come
on now. Go ahead and break their hearts.
They're all fucking chairman.
I remember when Yankee Stadium
used to get really loud,
I would get all fucking nervous going out.
God,
they just gonna we'll them in there.
What's fucking jade are going to do,
you know? Um, so anyways,
I can't believe that we want it and I
really thought that we were going to lose
that series.
And I also feel that if we fucking blue,
if we blew game four, I didn't see
us coming back winning game five. Um,
I just didn't.
So now we're under the fucking Houston
Astros who nobody is talking about for
whatever God damn reason
went through the Indians,
like a buzz saw and scary Terry Francona.
Um,
I dunno, l today and all of these
fucking guys, these guys are like,
these guys had dialed in. So we will
see how we do and we need fucking price
to, uh, to finally get a victory.
I know a lot of you guys do what's with
this we stuff, I hate people who say we,
well, I'll tell you why I
say we cause people go, if
you say we won, they're like,
oh you didn't win. But if you fucking
lose it's like yeah, you guys suck.
You know, you guys fucking suck. You guys
choked. You guys fucking blew it. Right?
But then all of a sudden you win if he
say if you use the Pronoun [inaudible]
right.
Can you still use that Pronoun by the way?
Or did somebody who wants to fucking have
that balls put on their knee and their
deck on their ear? Fucking we, who's we?
Me and my Dick and my balls.
I'm sorry.
Anyways, plowing ahead. So like
I mentioned, I'm in Saginaw,
Michigan and this is all leading up to uh,
my last big shows of the year,
November 7th.
I am going to be at Madison Square Garden.
I am going to be recording that night,
hopefully successfully this
time to put out a goddamn album.
Last time.
As you remember,
I had the set of my life and they didn't
understand what I was trying to do and
they only took the sound from the board.
So it was just me really
loud on my microphone.
Sounding ridiculously in front of
about eight people. Um, so I'm gonna try,
I'm gonna try to fucking do that again.
And then after that I have three nights
at the unbelievable Chicago theater,
arguably the greatest marquis.
I think it's the greatest marquis
and all these show business. Um,
and with that I would read
some advertising. There we
go. Um, oh look who's here,
right? All me go. Oh. Migo oh, me go.
Oh my go.
I'm never going to know how to say this.
A revolutionary toilet seat replacement.
Are you anal about
cleanliness in the bathroom?
What if I told you I could change
the way you poop? Jesus Christ.
Um,
have you ever really thought about poop?
That just sounds like a wet one coming
right out of your ass. You know,
it sounds like the noise it makes.
Have you ever really thought
about wiping with toilet paper?
Like really thought about it.
I'll give you a chance right now.
Motivate your audience. Talk about
your experience with all me. Go.
Oh my go. Uh, I haven't used it
yet. It sounds like the poor man's,
but a choose one to two copy points
to rotate in your spot. All right.
Washes you in all the right places.
Yo.
You take a shit you can wipe
your ass cheek all you want,
but that's not going to
fix the problem. Uh, that,
that's what they're doing in Washington.
Um, that would be my campaign slogan.
I think it's tying this country.
Stop wiping their ass cheeks and I got
down to business. What's the asshole? Oh,
I like this guy. He makes
sense. Pick talks like me.
Adjust the water temperature position,
pressure with movement.
Feels like you just took a shower.
I gotta tell you some,
I've used a bad day before. It was fuck
made me laugh my ass off, no pun intended.
But I cannot even begin to tell you the
fresh feeling I fed afterwards, you know.
Anyways, it feels like you just took
a shower. It features a heated seat,
a nightlife, soft closing,
air, dry, remote control.
Deodorize carbon filter eliminates odors.
Say Goodbye to toilet paper, save
trees, water and electricity.
US alone uses 36 million rolls
of toilet paper in one day.
It's quick and easy. I've come around
to these guys, you know what I mean?
Cause I know that that thing uses a bunch
of energy with the electricity and all
of that type of shit.
But you know,
there's not a bunch of paper going
into the water. At least this,
no separating that you have
to do down at the fucking Mil.
Whatever the hell they do anyways. Plus
you can install it in just 20 minutes,
20 minutes. Well, if you just
have an analog toilet seat,
I mean you can put it in about fucking
two minutes, but we'll it wash your ass.
You know, you can't have your
cake and eat it. People, uh,
do your business at Omi
go, oh Amigo. Oh my go. Uh,
getting $100 off on your order
when you go to m. Y. O, m, I,
g. O, d. O, t, c o m. Slash. B. U. R. R.
That's all me go. Oh my go. Oh,
am I a g o go to all me,
me, me, me, me, me. Go.
Dot Com slash burger at $100 off.
The future's weird at first.
Let it be weird. Ooh, get a little
creepy there in the end. All right.
Legal Zoom, legal, zoom. Uh,
you know the saying time is money.
It's true,
especially when you run your own business.
But running a successful business
involves taxes, contracts,
and a whole lot of fine print things
that eat up too much of your time. Well,
it's time to turn to legal zoom.
Over the last 17 years,
more than a million Americans have
used legal zoom to help launch their
businesses is as is.
But that's not the only thing.
Legal Zoom also has a network
of independent attorneys
and tax professionals who
can provide you with the advice you
need to get through the daily grind of
running your business.
And the best part is you don't have to
worry about driving to anyone's office or
being billed by the hour. Uh,
since legal zoom is not a law firm,
you can count on legal zoom to provide
the business resources you need and
services that fits your schedule services.
Wait,
invest your time and your money into
your growing business and let legal zoom
help with the legit stuff.
Go to legal zoom.com now,
capital letters and use code burpee. You
are are at checkout for special savings.
Once again,
that's Promo Code Bar at legal zoom
legal zoom where life meets legal.
Oh, last but not least. Oh, I
like these guys. Butcher box,
butcher blocks, dude. Um,
butcher box delivers healthy 100% grass
fed and grass finished beef free range,
organic chicken and heritage, bread, pork.
The greatest fucking meat I've
ever tasted in my life in my house.
I felt like a five star chef for those
who don't know what heritage bread,
pork is, that, that,
that is uh, that is um,
pure bred pigs that they can trace
their bloodline back to Europe.
All right. This is, this is the like,
I can't tell you [inaudible] just going
to compare it to fuck, I can't do that.
Cause then they going to be like,
can you please not compare us to the clan?
Um,
yeah.
If you want to get racist with your pork
or it'd be a little nice if you want to
go Westminster with your pork.
That's I'm telling you dude,
you fucking make to sear it on both sides.
Finish it in the oven in a skillet.
You bring it back out. A little rosemary
butter bath. Oh, forget about it.
Unbelievable.
The incredible quality of butcher box
meat starts with the commitment to raising
animals humanely and free of antibiotics
and hormones before they kill them.
Each box comes with at least
nine to 11 pounds of meat,
which is enough for 24 individual size
meals. Unless you're a glutton is fat.
Fuck,
you'll probably blow through it in days.
You can choose from five different box
types. All beef, beef and chicken. Ooh,
beef and pork mixed box.
We are the world custom box
lets you choose your own cuts.
Antibiotic Hormone Free
Butcher box believes in health,
a healthier food system.
Good for them,
where everyone has access to
meets the way nature intended.
Free of antibiotics,
free of hormones,
and humanely raised on an open
pasture before they murder them.
Selection,
butcher block carefully cure rates to
find a selections and cuts and makes it a
breeze.
To customize your own delivery,
build your own box to get exactly
what you and your family love.
Choose your delivery frequency with
the customizable subscription. Uh,
recipes are available on butcher box
websites and videos are available to them
to follow along on butcher
box youtube channel.
I already gave my personal experience,
uh,
for Free Bacon and $20 off your first box.
Go to butcher box.com and enter Promo
Code bird that's $20 off and Free Bacon
Promo Code Bar. All
right? You know something.
You know what the one that when Peter
always shows those things about animals,
you don't want one that really
fucking got me the other day.
I can't remember if I mentioned
this on the Monday morning podcast.
I was driving down to this
gig in Bridgeport and right
next to the place that I
was playing,
they had this sign would that showed a
cow and then it's calf and the calf was
like touching face with its with
its mother, you know what I mean?
Like this beautiful, you know,
mother kid fucking type of vibe.
And it said this is this calves first
day and last day with his mother,
please stop drinking milk.
And I was like, Jesus Christ.
You know, now I'm, I'm
separating families,
you know,
I dunno. I Dunno what's going on with
the fucking world right now. Right.
But I,
I'm gonna I'm starting
with the cut in the mirror.
MMM MMM.
Asking him to change his freckles.
Those were the original lyrics. I actually
wrote that and I sent it to Michael.
He's like, oh, it seems a little
ginger specific. And I said,
don't use that word around me
or I'll do something offensive to your
race if I could figure out what the fuck.
Um,
yeah,
I am. I am working on
my temper. I am, I am.
I'm not going to get into arguments
about people with their fucking belief
system. I would like to fucking, you know,
I'm not saying that we're going to become
vegetarian, but like I would like to,
where do they continue to promote more
companies that at least they're saying
they're doing this. I hope
they're not fucking lion. And uh,
I gotta be honest with you, man, I've
switched over to fucking almond milk.
But here's the thing about almonds.
They take up so much goddamn water grow
and then, you know, there's
just too many fucking people.
It always comes down to that.
How do we live on this planet?
We need to get the fucking
population Dachau, right?
That's what we need to do.
Okay.
We need to stop fighting
about the goop in the ground.
We just stop fucking screaming and
yelling at each other. We got it.
It's like we have an a tug of war
when we should just fucking, I dunno,
you can't do it.
How do you get on the same page?
How do you get everybody to start
pulling in the same fucking direction?
Do you know,
like when they take a black light and
they go through like a fucking hotel room
to see where all the fucking Jesus,
if they could come up with one of those
lights for socio paths and I don't know
what you would do with those people.
I mean,
I think you've got to take them out and
you certainly can't stick them on an
island and have all of those fucking
lunatics there at the same time.
There's another great Scifi movie,
somebody invents at Tj's
light for fucking sociopaths.
They weed them all out,
but there's, but they're,
they're big flaw in their
system is their fucking liberal.
So they can't flip the switch
and electrocute him and
they stick them all on the
same island and then they just
create a master race of socio paths.
And then they had this war,
like psychotic fucking people.
And then they get in their goddamn viking
ships and they start coming over to
everybody else walking around with
their Beta energy in their Birkenstocks.
All right.
And of course there's one good
one over there. I Dunno why.
Somehow there's some sort of fucking
lefty gene. It's, it's Hollywood.
It's going to have to be the lefties
saved, saving the fucking day. Right? Um,
he gets over there and he warns him and
he has to teach all of these fucking
Bergen stocked fucking leftys how to
fight fire with fire and become warlike.
All right.
It's basically empire strikes
back meets police academy.
That's how I would pitch it.
All right.
With a sprinkle of the Dave Matthews band.
All right. That's your dump
Scifi movie of the week. Um,
all right. Now as a red
sox fan, I have one more.
I got to tip my cap one more time out.
Up on a percent respect for the
Yankees in their organization.
Do you realize that if the New York
Yankees do not win the world series next
year,
this will only be the second
decade since the 1920s that they,
that they didn't win a world series?
Do you want to stand? Let's, let's,
let's fucking look this up
here for a second. All right.
If you want to get jealous
as a fucking sports fan,
New New York Yankees.
Don't you will see fucking
sang about New Jersey. Frank,
just as a fuck you to New York.
They never thought he was good
enough until he was good enough.
Then they took him in as
their own. Um, you know,
I want to wake up and a city
that fucking rakes, right?
He's singing about Newark and
fight dom bridge and tunnel
to noon. I will sleep. Sorry.
Had to rhyme. All right. New York
Yankees. Where the fuck, let me hit pause
so this doesn't take forever. All right.
I only had to put a pause for two
seconds. All right. The 1920s. All right.
1919 they get babe Ruth. Okay.
The 1920s they won three titles.
19 231927192080,
here come the 1930s they one night
they went one, two, three, four,
five,
1930 to 1936 93719381939
including four in a row.
They want to half the fucking
world series in that decade.
1940s they won one,
two three four.
They had an off decade.
They only won four 1940 94319471949 and
then here come the 1950s where they one,
one, two, three four five,
six including five in a row.
If you count 1949 cause they already
won 1949 then they want 95019511952 and
1953 then they won 1956
and 1958 by the way,
honorable mention to the Cleveland
Indians when they won in 1946 I believe,
or was it 48 I can't remember.
48 I think. All right.
Then the 1960s they want to 1961 1962
then the 70s they want to 1977 1978 now
granted now this like fucking,
you know,
25 30 teams in the league and there's
still one in the 80s they don't win any
silly one twenties thirties forties
fifties sixties seventies
six fucking decades in a row.
2000 they come right back and they
went 390690890 nine to 2000 they,
when they won in 2000 2009 they want to,
how do you count the decades by the way?
You count it from sometimes. Is
it 81 to 90? I don't know. I,
when the odometer flips, that's
how I count it. All right?
So they have yet to win one this decade.
So they've basically,
one of the last nine decades
they won a championship.
Like a drought for them is
not winning in a decade.
It's fucking ridiculous.
It really is ridiculous.
And they have more titles than the
Celtics. More titles, the Lakers,
more titles than the fucking,
okay.
Montreal Canadians,
more titles than the fucking Green Bay
packers with all of their Superbowls in
all of their fucking super bowl titles and
the Pittsburgh Steelers Superbowls
thrown in. So there you go. And,
and I think that they're going to win
one here in the next couple of years,
the direction that they're going. So, uh,
I'm very happy that we were able
to beat them. And like I said,
I don't fucking rub it in. I got nothing
but respect for him. That's the podcast.
Um, be sure to listen now
to do my, my fucking picks,
my NFL picks for the week,
which uh, you know, I barely,
you know, I don't have
time to pay a to, I should,
I really should start playing fantasy
football so I know who some of the fucking
people are in the league.
Um,
so I'm on the on green and Ryan Kramer
show the sports gambling podcast.
Um, and that's it. Other than that,
after that we'll have a little bit of
music and then a throwback from a podcast
from a Thursday going by earlier this
year or God knows when. All right,
that's it. Go Red Sox. Uh,
go pats and all of this stupid mouth
breathers and shit that I watch.
[inaudible] hey we,
we got him,
we stopped.
We can be
[inaudible] [inaudible]
Jane
[inaudible]
we're on the sports gaming podcast
is brought to you by my book.
He died a g my book.
He is the leader in online sports books.
You use the Promo Code Bill
bets for a 100% deposit bonus,
play Wayne and get paid. And My bookie.
Dot. Agee joining us on the line.
Bill Burr.
Bill,
your red socks just defeated the
Yankees in the alds three to one. How,
how excited are you for them to move on?
I can't believe how much I still care.
I was trying to lie to him cause I didn't,
I don't feel, you know, the
rent price was touching.
I was like you need a one to or not
the great teams like the Yankees out.
And I was just,
you know,
all I wanted to see him was one and once
the movie was over and roll credits,
I mean what are they going to do?
Chat 2013 at me.
I said all of that stuff
and I couldn't believe
how much,
you know what it is.
It's not the Yankees
and it's not the worst
and association. It's their fans. It's
really,
and it's not even all of this fans.
It's those mouth breathing morons
that those mole fans, you know,
the guys who like ducked
down when they lose.
And then pop their head up when they,
when I literally have a friend,
I'm not going to sign up front. I
got a coworker, another comedian.
I didn't hear from that guy since game
three to 2014 I'm 2004 I didn't hear from
him again until the red sox blew that
lead with Bobby Valentine and September in
2012 like nine years later he popped
his head up to start talking trash.
The next year we won the world series.
I haven't heard from him again.
Cabling guarantee you if the Yankees won
this thing that I would have heard from.
That's only time I hear from this guy
is when the Yankees beat the red sox.
Well, yeah. Why not? Why
not? I mean, I do agree.
There was a great shot during the game
last night where they had this trio of
like just straight from the
Bronx like slightly before.
Yeah. When he struck that guy out, will
they, they honestly, they
make me, I mean as a Yang,
I grew up in New Jersey as a Yankee Fan.
It did make me kind of question like,
man, I'm associating with these
neanderthals. Like there is,
there is a certain element
of the, the annoyance of the,
the, the casual bandwagon.
Yankee.
One thing we have in common though,
red sox and Yankees is the
level of mouth breathing.
I mean when they,
when they cut to the crowd,
but they're jealous just hanging open.
It's like wholesome looking or whatever.
The west coast has their own vibe.
Florida in the south, you're
lucky if they even show up. Right.
But like you get to the east coast,
Philly, New York, Boston, we are,
we're animals and you can't
even deny it or just animal
I, and as someone who's lived now
in California for about 15 years,
you really start to notice it.
The longer you're away from it,
it stops being normal. And you go back
home and you're like, oh my God, this is,
having said that you can get stabbed
to death at a game on the west coast.
Yeah. That's all. They skipped the
whole dump in the beer over your head.
They just don't write
up, you know, a homicide.
Yeah, that's, that's the
thing. As an eagles fan, we
always get so much shit. Oh,
you guys are the worst fans.
You guys are mean.
You guys booed Santa Claus
in through Sovos. Meanwhile,
Dodgers fans are putting guys in comas
and and stabbing people died over,
over, over a Dodgers game, a game that
you know, barely the city cares about.
What's going to choice for Philadelphia
is the d cell battery and that's,
that's honorable. Not a,
not a knife. What's wrong?
Medium. That's medium security.
If you go to jail. Yeah, yeah.
No.
They had the jail at Eagle Eagle Stadium.
If they had one out here in a would
have to be, you have to be a prison.
I was the crime that was committed.
It wouldn't be like some,
some silly drunken behavior.
Yeah. You're not getting a couple of days.
You're going away for a good long time.
Yeah, exactly. And the crazy Dodgers
stadium, you can't even tailgate.
They won't let you drink beer. Sir. If you
could move on to the stadium. Thank you.
Yeah.
The one time I had a couple of beers in
the parking lot was playing some wiffle
ball.
Assuming that's kind of what you do
before a baseball game and a guy in a golf
cart came up, took my id and said
I was on the list. So I dunno.
What list would list them on at dodger
stadium? Why did you give him your id?
You know what? I should have a, I should
have just said, who the fuck are you?
Why would I give, listen, I
was, I was confronted. I was
hopping cars have doors. Yeah. Yo,
I don't know how
combustion engines,
why don't you go back to a criminal
justice school and get your degree there?
Yeah. I don't know how
would even determine. Yeah,
it's unclear how you would detain me.
You put me back where the golf clubs
are supposed to be and like tie me in.
Very unclear. Oh yeah. I Dunno. I Dunno.
Show, so that's exciting. Let's talk.
Let's talk about the
national football league.
Of course that bill's going to be
making some pics. He's on the line,
courtesy of my bookie dad, agg,
the official online sports.
Look at the sports game like podcasts,
hundred percent deposit bonus
using the Promo Code bill bets.
First game that we got here to select
is a the eagles minus three edit into
giant stadium. Nscs doesn't look
great. Eagle can give mouth breathers.
Yeah, there's going to be a lot of mouth
breathing going on. All the eagles,
two and three giants, one in for the
NFC east, not looking great bill. Uh,
which way you lean in this game?
I were take the giants were, oh,
okay. I get in three. Yep. They're a,
they're the home guys. Two or three
and I'm going to, I just, you know,
those division rivalry games that they
lost the giant foster heartbreaker last
year. I mean they, they should, they
should be two orders. What does it really,
one in four. So they should be
a, it was at two and three. Yeah.
They're not as bad as their
record. And uh, I don't know.
I don't know much about the eagles by
imagine. After they won a Superbowl,
a bunch of guys in their team went out
and got that free agency money and some
coaches left.
So there's always a bit of a hangover
trying to figure out who you all after
that. Speaking as a patriots
fan considerably want so
many this century, you know,
I can actually speak
with this with authority.
Um, yeah. I mean it's not a
good sign when I, you know,
there's multiple book tours going for
like I read a backup quarterback's book in
the off season,
so that's maybe the,
maybe the team did get a little
ahead of themselves there.
Yeah, there's still celebrate. Yeah,
they'd probably hanging out with the
Vatican if can you believe we want it to
um, to doing beer bottles.
Take A, I would shake, uh,
Eli in the points at, Huh? Alright.
Kramer. I'm guessing you're rowing,
you're going giants. Why are
you going? Gee Man. Well,
I mean it's the same thing we've told
the defense doesn't play as well on the
road.
And Carson Wentz,
just like the doctor said he's got
all the way back and the offense is,
there's no magic.
Like the head coach is not,
he's not having those magical fourth
down Philly Philly calls and yeah,
like bill said,
giants not as bad.
They've got hosed by the rafts
and an awesome kick last week.
So of course I'm on the
giants. Home team is Fay. Hey,
home team is called covered every home
Thursday night game. So that, that's true.
But here's what I'll say.
Eagles 16 and four in the last 20,
they have eli Manning's number
also. You Brian, your giants.
What are they horrible at covering
the tight end. A lot of sense. Yeah.
Well exactly. But Zach
hurts. He's uh, you know,
he's The star right now on offense
your nation, Bro. You're reaching,
no, I, I, I think they go in,
this is a must win for the eagles.
I just don't think this
giants offensive line,
we'll be able to keep the Eagles'
defensive line, which has been struggling.
No such thing as a must win for the ego.
So just won the,
all right, go ahead. I
know that's the problem.
They got a free pass for
the rest of my life, but I,
I wear or the dog mass that they're gone.
They're not the dog anymore.
They're the targeted.
So they are the road favor
defending champs and they got their feet
up. Take the points. Nah, I'm saying,
I'm saying eagles.
Mine is three road victory. No
sweat here. All right, here's the,
here's an interesting one.
Played Out in Wembley Stadium,
the Seahawks minus three,
I guess technically a home game
for the Raiders. They're fine.
They're playing some real
football out in London. Bill, uh,
which way you lean in on this game?
Well,
I love John Grown,
but I still don't think he's gotten
his team where it needs to be.
And uh, Pete Carroll is a
beast and I just, I, you know,
I don't even think we were playing
over in Europe last time and coached.
He's got the oldest team in the NFL. They
going to be all cranky from the flight.
I don't know. I, I've taken, um, what,
what's the, see, what am I see asks, given
Seahawks are only laying three.
Yeah.
Only that I don't like you just said only.
Awesome. That's a wrap already. I'm
already tipping my hand, I guess.
I think, uh, yeah,
I think they're going to have problems
contained in their quarterback.
They'd Raiders left from obtaining
their, uh, their quarterback is, I,
I'm going to go to Seattle.
Yeah. I mean, I just want, I want
to see the, I just want to see this,
the documentary on Gruden in London.
That's all John Gruden said. Quote,
he's not a good flier and
gets anxious online. Long
plane rides. Interesting fact.
The Raiders, uh, they're not
flying out to London till Friday,
which I always feel is a bad sign.
Carol, he got on the plane, uh,
you know, a couple of days early. So the
Seahawks are already out in London. I,
I think that's
already walked around. Buckingham Palace
gone. Whew. Anytime anything could happen.
Yes.
The ric flair.
He is kind of scary when a,
when a old guy choose that much
gum and has that much energy, it's,
it's a little unsettling.
Okay. What's on real? He's the oldest
coach in the NFL. He looks great.
He looks great. Dude. He's
like the Dick Clark or coaches.
Yeah. He's almost, he's kind
of reminds me of Jack Lane.
Just like an old guy. Gray
hair. Super jacked. Tons of
energy. He must be juicing.
Yeah. Or something. Juice
in the positive way.
Yeah. Classic Classic Seattle Guy. I
listen, I know you don't want to say,
uh, the Seahawks, that was kind of their
super bowl ad home against the rams.
They lost that game. That
was a tough loss. Maybe they,
maybe they don't get up for this game,
but I,
I just don't think this
or Raiders team is right.
Gruden I think is having trouble
adjusting to the modern game.
He hasn't been able to fix car. I just
don't see the Raiders showing up short.
When's the last time you flew?
Like a nine hour flight and then
you play a game 18 hours later.
But that doesn't seem right.
I usually have to sleep for a
solid eight to 10 hours out. Yeah.
Still buy a thing is that they're,
they're avoiding London's food.
That's a good thing that that could
play to their advantage. Yeah.
Any of them are listening. Go there and
get the Indian food accounts standing.
Avoid the accident. Yeah. Yeah.
Avoid the food. They actually make
John Gruden with a giant
plate of bangers and mash
tires in Macedonia. English, breakfast or
anything. Just give a couple of Fridays
blood pudding. Oh yeah. Super Gross.
Sounds. Sounds delicious. Yeah, I just, I,
I think there's plenty of science and
I'm sure grins not up on the science. I,
there's plenty of science on
why you want to get there early.
So just knowing that I love the Seahawks.
Yeah.
Good spot for the Seahawks.
Good matchup.
Final game of the three
we're picking with bill here,
the Kansas City chiefs head into New
England for Sunday night football.
Right now the pats
coming off the long rest,
three and a half point home favorites
against the Kansas City chiefs
if favorites.
You know what?
This is such a weird game because the
Jag was manhandled the patrons and then
Kansas City planted the jags like a month
later and Blake Bortles look like he
shouldn't even be in the NFL.
So it's one of those things was like
when the Patriots played the Jaguars was
where the Patriots not as bad as they
seem in the Jaguar's worn is good or this
Kansas City.
That's good.
MMM.
Oh three points at home. This is the
thing why I'm going to take the Patriots,
which this makes me nervous.
Yeah. I wouldn't have a
tease this game either. Um,
the only thing that you don't like,
the thing that's tipping it is that uh,
Kansas City has the worst defense.
Yeah.
And I I'm not buying last week even though
they look solid. Um, just not buy out.
I don't know cause I don't think are,
I don't think our defense is good and
I was kind of making fun of how much,
you know, the attach Oklahoma's,
I mean the way the hype and the,
he is said Brady has
rings show tie my homes.
I hope you want allows what you just
thought that I stopped at five to that a
thousand. Everybody relax. I think
it's cause Brady's going to leave soon.
Drew Brees, he's going to leave
soon and they, they, they, they're,
they need somebody to, uh, to step it up.
And I think that guy
will step it up. Um, uh,
and they also shall act as a year ago.
Does.
But are there enough guys left
on the team that care? Um,
Brady Brady cares and he's got
Adelman back and he stepped up.
The guy that likes to have a
few from Cleveland. Josh Gordon.
Yeah. Good Lord. What are you, you know
what? I'm going to go with the Patriots.
I can't, I can't take them. I just let
people listen. Don't take that as advice.
That's my art time.
This is a really great time to sell
the chief stock. And Sean, you,
we like to look at what
the public's up to. Yes.
68% of the tickets on the chiefs and yet
this line has gone from three to three
and a half. What does that tell you?
Sharp. Smart money is on the Patriots.
The Hook is there to scare you.
Lay the hook. Come on. This is,
this is the classic like, Hey, Andy, read,
beat the shit out of bill
Belichick week one last year.
You think Bella check doesn't
remember that. Yeah, I just don't see
Canton street is a monster in September.
The last guy you want to run into,
what steps you actually look in
January. He's, he's a little tired.
He's kind of a monster year
round. Big Fella. But uh,
Oh man,
I always crack up the way that the Koolaid
Gif of him running through the wall
or the punt pass and kick that they
always show of him going up against other
eight nine year olds when he was eight,
nine and he was still like twice
their size. Listen, Andy Reid, great.
He competed in one of those.
Oh yeah, I'll have to send you the
video. It's, it's an all time classic.
He's literally two and a half times
the size of all the other kids.
God bless him.
He's a kid,
he's a good coach. But the pets,
they have that extra rest. Uh,
and I think they kind of figured
out their offense and the chiefs,
the defensive backfield is not right.
Like the jags offense on the
road is way different than uh,
than the pets at home. So,
uh, I think the patriots,
they covered the three and a half.
Yeah.
I think. How would you play a different
defense when you're on the road?
They do you, do you honestly
think that crowd makes that they,
I don't understand this.
Those guys have like literally 300 pound
people running at a metaphor for like,
and they're worried about some
guy dressed up like Boba Fett.
Oh my God. That face paint threw me off.
I think really what it is is a, they,
they talk so much about how the snap
count makes a huge difference where the
office that they're going up
against when they're at home,
they have to go on silent
count a lot and it's,
it's much easier to get a better jump on
the ball when you're on the road. The,
the crowd noise is against
you. And a, I think it makes,
and not to mention it's though those
late nights cause you're on the road,
which means you're probably dabbling in
some side action. Lawrence Taylor style,
the prostitutes come into the hotel.
I don't know if you can do that
now with cell phone cameras.
That's true. That's true. That's a real,
it's a simpler back when lt could just,
every team has a ray Donovan.
I'm sure of that.
It does seem like there's, there's
probably some still shenanigans going on.
Kramer close things out here. Are
you on the paths as well? Yeah, no,
I'm definitely, I think,
you know, I like to play,
I play against the market and I think
everyone sees the chiefs and like bill was
saying like Pat Ma homes can do no wrong.
Yeah,
he's the greatest thing
since exactly the luck.
The reaction to the lefthanded
throw was like, Oh man,
he has three of those in his career.
Like that's not a sign of a great app.
He came in as a ledger, like five
stars. It's already a legend.
So, and now their comparison
comparing him to Steph curry and it's,
it's a little bit like, no one's
willing to say it, but like,
are we just saying this
because he's light skinned all,
I mean it's a light skinned black guy
with curly hair and all of a sudden
they're the same play and nothing.
Nothing like Steph curry at all.
Like how is slinging 80
mile an hour fastball?
Football's anything like shooting a three
pointer. Nothing. I, anyway, good. Sorry.
Good time to sell on the pats or
sorry, sell. In this case, the chiefs,
I'm buying the patch.
I Pat,
you could've gotten the pats to win
that division a week or two ago for like
minus 300. It's now
minus 900 Sean. Ah Man.
See you said easy money every year.
Oh,
he's just passing up on the
pats to win the division. Just,
it's better than any sort of stack
you can invest in. All right, Bill,
before we let you go, throw at a,
uh, throw it a lock for a week,
six here in the NFL.
Ah, God, I didn't have a chance to look
at it. So I gotta go outside the lock.
I Dunno. Any, any other sort of
a lead pipe predictions that you
for this weekend patriots beat Kansas
Shitty will then be odds on favorite to
win the Superbowl we lose to Kansas City.
They'll start asking is this
Brady's last year? That's my lock.
Lock it up. I like it. Has
he fallen off the clay?
Wouldn't be the first time the chiefs
we achieved defeat of the Patriots.
Turned into is this the end for Brady? Is
this the end? It's got to end sometime.
Could this be the year and he's, he's got
that trainer. He'll be good for awhile.
Yeah,
him and Greg got it
figured out. Spongy muscle.
I've heard about that.
It's not all hard and
all tight and everything.
It's like when you know when
you're going to do the dishes,
you know that little sponge.
It's like malleable.
It's Tom Brady's name.
Go Watch this dude.
Run the 40 at the combine and tell me
he's not a better athlete at 41 like what?
What somethings is going on. Come
on, something's going on. He's,
he's getting younger as time goes
on. But, uh, yeah, clearly the
Pat's aren't done. Colby thing. He
probably got his blood spun. Yeah.
Got some stem cells in there, a
couple of embryos. He, you know,
he uses that as a pillow or something.
I don't know what he's doing.
He looks amazing.
Sure does. All right, we'll uh, bill,
appreciate you calling in. As always,
make sure you guys check out.
F is for family season three coming out
in November on Netflix. Vince Vaughn,
join in the CAS and a as always,
appreciate you calling in.
All right guys, thanks so much
for having me. I appreciate it.
Once again, Bill burr brought to you by
the good folks over at my bookie. Dot.
Agee, the official online sports
book of the sports gambling podcast.
Use that Promo Code Bill bets
for a 100% deposit bonus.
Play when and get paid over
at my bookie. Dot. Agee.
Hey,
we can be
[inaudible]
is that time?
What's going on? It's bill burr and it's
the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
October 11th, 2010. How the hell
are you? Are you doing good?
Well that's good.
Um,
I had all this shit that I wanted to talk
about and then I was looking at these
fucking emails and right off the
Bat I got one from Lo and behold,
douche bag or the fucking week.
Guy's name's Brad course.
It's fucking names. Brad,
you know what else? What?
What a what a mother and
father name a Douche bag baby.
Other than Brad. This is from Brad. Bill.
I was hoping that I could
find your podcast on iTunes.
Yet another week passes by where your
fans can not listen to your show.
No problem with that. Right
to there. Then he goes,
you might want to make that
a priority sometime too.
I can just fucking see his bare
feet and his fucking penny loafers.
What are you leaning on my
cubicle? You fucking cunt. Really?
Do I really want to make that a priority?
You dumb.
Fuck you don't think I'm not
trying to contact iTunes.
They don't have a fucking
person who answers their phones.
They ignore my God damn emails. What am
I supposed to do? Go down to main street,
right down on main street to the fucking
mom and pop fucking Mr Mrs Itunes store.
It doesn't exist.
You douche.
You might want to make that
a priority fucking soon.
I want to slap you
right in your privilege.
Fucking Connecticut white face and I
don't give a fuck if you're not white and
even not from Connecticut cause you
should be what? That fucking tone. What?
I can't contact
the week Brad,
go fuck yourself. All right. I'm trying
to get this thing back up on iTunes.
They're not responding to me.
What am I supposed to do?
They don't have a location.
This is the exact shit I've been
fucking trying to tell you guys about.
It starts with those Goddamn automated
machines down at the fucking grocery
store.
You're siding with the fucking robots.
Some of that made sense. You know what
did seriously, this is the future.
This is what a store is going to be.
You're not going to be able to
get in contact with anybody.
You're going to have a problem and you
can basically go fuck yourself and then
some other fucking nerd whose only job
is going to be fucking greasy elbow with
a fucking robot that took his
job is going to send me an email.
Tell me that I need to
make something a priority.
Why don't you go fuck yourself
buddy there that why don't you?
Why don't you make that a priority
sometimes soon. All right.
What? Fuck it. I swear to God you are.
You might want to make that a
priority sometimes soon. Oh,
the fucking stuffed shirt.
Fucking hang you by your goddamn tie,
Brad. You fucking cunt. Go Fuck Yourself.
I'm glad you told all your friends to
listen to it and now they can't. Huh?
What's that fucking with
you and your God Damn Ego.
Do you have a position at work?
Little fucking corner office. Brad
fucking moron telling me I need
breathing.
You might want to make that a priority
once you tell me something fucking else
obvious. All right, there you go.
There's your head of steam for the week.
Douche bag of the week. Good
old bread. I had no idea really.
If it wasn't on iTunes and people
couldn't download in anymore,
like that would present some sort of
a problem and dropped my listenership.
You think? I don't realize
that Brad, you fucking Dick
on Columbus Day.
Can you believe I'm in this kind of a
fucking move on Columbus Day? You know,
this is a great day and sort of white
history when that Spaniard came over here,
who kind of look white because of his
brown hair. Did he have brown hair?
Wasn't he Spanish or did he just
sail for the Spanish? I can't even,
I can't even fucking keep the
damn story straight. All right.
In my fucking history book,
he had yellow hair, you know,
and shiny teeth in a fucking,
you know,
he was in shape. Then all of a
sudden they make a movie of vitamins.
Jerrad Deborah Dude.
And he play him that French fuck.
He played him and he didn't
even land in Florida.
He lands a islands down in the,
uh,
the Caribbean starts
cutting people's hands off.
Cause then I'd find him blood diamonds.
So, which was it? You don't want to.
I love, I love like when they have like
a, like a story. Everybody's going by,
right about some shit that
happened fucking 500 years ago,
whatever thousand years ago.
Then out of nowhere,
there'll be a show on TV and they'll
say new evidence suggests new evidence.
Five something from 500 years
and yet new evidence. Really?
Where the fuck did you find it?
That that Christopher Columbus write
something down on a cocktail napkin in a
bar and somebody finally
cleaned out the fucking,
those rubber mats that they
stand on and they found it. Oh,
this evidently he went down to the
Caribbean and chop people's hands off for
some reason. Wrote it all over
this cocktail napkin. You know,
I see some stuff. You know, where
we thought the world was flat.
New evidence suggests that maybe he
didn't sail off the edge of the world.
Maybe his fucking boat sank in a storm. I
can see that, that sort of new evidence,
but I mean, what, what sort of
new evidence did you find? Huh?
Some fucking old lady used to bang,
I guess when she was fucking not
even a fetus and she's still alive.
I actually knew Christopher Columbus.
He was a murderer in son of a bitch.
I don't know who the fuck
knows what happened. I just
like bringing that shit up.
So then people who were into that stuff
can then send me a five page email,
you know, or the lazy ones who
then just search it, find it,
and then paste the link
like they're an expert.
I'm lashing out at everybody this week.
It's Christopher Columbus Day. Everybody,
you know, and thank God he
discovered America or else
we wouldn't have been here.
Think about what would have happened.
What wouldn't have happened if he
didn't come over here? You know,
from slavery to cheesecake factory's,
none of that would have
been a possibility here.
If that fucking greedy son of a bitch.
They actually took a lot of balls.
He, I think he's the first x
Gamer. You know what I mean?
He just said fun. Is that
really is, was he a scientist?
Where did Christopher Columbus get the
balls? Because I'll tell you right now,
me being the afraid of technology
person that I am afraid of change.
You know there's no fucking way
I would've gotten that boat.
There's no goddamn way.
I know the world's round and I
won't get on a fucking boat today.
What do you think about that?
Are you afraid that it's going to sink
bill? Yes I am. That's what I'm afraid of.
I'm afraid I'm going to survive it and
then sit there and pray that hypothermia
sets in in numbs me up so I don't feel
it when the fucking tiger shark starts
nibbling on one of my
fucking pasty thighs.
I'm sorry guys.
This is really fucking angry.
That guy just really set me off where
the devacy exact fucking reason why I
became a goddamn comedian,
cause I don't want to ever be in a
position where some douche comes over,
leans over into my life and tells me
what I might want to make a fucking
priority. You condescending. Fuck.
What kind of a mouse of
a woman did you marry?
She's probably downstairs
right now making a Voodoo doll.
You and your fucking Docker's
the affect gut hanging out.
You wouldn't have those guys. Huh? Yo,
he's got to wear the sport coat and no
one knows how fat you are until till they
have the office fucking let's go play
Frisbee party and then you show up with
your fucking man tits,
heart disease buddy.
That's what I wish on you. Go Fuck
Yourself. Listen to another podcast.
You might want to make that a priority.
All right,
so let's get on with the hyping
for this week. I have, um,
I have a new show. Did, I actually
haven't even hyped on here. Uh,
it's the last second. I'm going to
be at the Wilbur Theater in Boston,
Massachusetts and I am doing a comedy
show actually from my brother who was
running for state Senate in Massachusetts.
And a all proceeds will go after
we paid for the theater and uh,
the state tax at a though, you know,
God knows what else you got to pay,
but all the proceeds are
going to go towards, uh,
helping him out with his campaign. So, um,
that's it.
All right.
It's going to be October 20th
at the Wilbur Theater in,
uh, Boston, Massachusetts.
So come on down,
come on down and watch me dance around
like a monkey for a fucking hour and a,
and we'll raise some money
for my brother's campaign.
There you go. There you go.
You know,
you might want to make that a priority.
I'm not gonna be able to get
that out of my fucking head.
That's the exact reason.
That's why I worked in,
that's why I worked in the warehouse.
I never went into the carpeted area
because I saw those fucking people.
They had to sit there at that
Goddamn desk. And you just saw,
he saw the back of their necks when
you came, you said, you know, Hey Mike,
he just saw the shoulders come up a little
bit because they thought it was that
cunt in the office who leans over to
tell them what they might want to make a
fucking priority.
All right.
Okay, I am back. Um,
let's talk NFL football.
Everybody. Let's fucking just drive
that subject into the Goddamn ground,
shall we? Um, now fuck that. We'll
get to that a little bit later.
Um, let's talk about
online banking. Shall We?
[inaudible] was listening to am
radio this week. You know why?
Cause I'm a big fan of
the fill Henry show.
So I was listening to that and I just
woke up the next day and I still had it on
that. And uh, you know,
there was this one show with this
guy was as left as Fox is right.
And it was just,
it was completely asinine.
And he was making the usual
statements that idiots make who,
who host those shows or
listened to those shows.
He started saying something
dumb about like, uh, you know,
when Republicans lie in Washington, no
one cares. Nobody does anything about it.
But if a Democrat, Lars, they just
hold their feet to the fire, you know,
that dumb shit. You know,
they could do whatever they
want, but if we do something,
but it's like really,
you don't think that you're so
far to one side that maybe you're,
you're just a little bit
clouded in your vision.
You don't really fucking notice
like a sports fan, you know,
like a Yankee Fan,
right?
Some fucking eight year old pulls
a routine fly ball into the stands.
As long as it's a home run for your
team, you don't give a fuck. Right?
Then all of a sudden if someone on
the other team is fucking around,
then it's a major God damn problem.
Like every fan I should've just picked
on the Yankee fans should I have,
I'll tell you, that was an amazing victory
they had over the twins. You see that?
They fucking swept those sons of bitches
right on the rug. How'd you like that?
Minnesota with the new stadium.
Uh,
what'd you think that was
going to make a difference?
Maybe if we play outside we won't get
our asses kicked. Do you understand that?
You're a mom and pop store out there
and you're going up against Walmart.
All right. Get your grandmother
off the front porch with a shotgun.
It's fucking over.
Um,
this is how much I don't watch baseball.
I thought the reds were in last place
like they have been for like the last 10
years. So it was kind of exciting to
see them in a first, uh, you know,
playing in the playoffs a little.
The Phillies were spanking
their fucking ass. I know,
I got a weird relationship with
Cincinnati. They beat my red sox in 1975.
So one of the first memories
I have of being a sports fan,
I didn't really know what was going on.
I just remember hearing my dad's
screaming at the fucking TV. Um,
so they beat us then, but then I don't,
I kinda liked him. I always liked, uh,
I love was a big national
league fan in the 80s.
I like the astroturf people stole basis.
I thought, I thought astro turf was cool.
That's how much of a child of the
70s and eighties I was. But um,
I don't know.
Now they're back kind of rooting for them.
But I had such a shit weekend last time
I was out there and fucking nor Kentucky
and being in downtown Cincinnati where
there was just absolutely nothing going
on plus past 5:00 PM that you want
to be involved in. So I don't know.
I think I'm rooting for the
Phillies. Does that, my team,
obviously anybody who plays the fucking
Yankees I'm going to root against,
but you know, uh, you son of a bitch.
You guys want to hear me take a phone
call? Huh? Business phone call. Hello?
What's going on, Josh? How are you?
Do I sound odd right
now it's because I'm a,
I'm in the middle of doing my podcast
and you're not really on the air.
You're,
you're up to my ear so no
one can really hear anything.
So if you want to trash these fucking
morons, then I'm morons. You know,
it was just one person pissed me off,
told me something that I need to make
a priority on my podcast and suddenly I
felt like I had a day job.
You want to email me those flights and
that stuff and I'll look at it after the
podcast.
Oh, Jesus. Okay.
All right. Hang on one second.
Hang on. Hang on. Hang on. Hang on.
All right, I'm back. Sorry. That
turned out to be way more important.
I thought it was going to say,
do you want to fly to Seattle?
At this hour or this hour. Um, and he was,
what the hell was I talking about?
God dammit.
Just talking about Democrats,
Republicans at Javits. Who gives a fuck?
Let's talk about, oh, it's talking
about baseball. Talk about, basically,
I don't even know what's
going on in there.
I know Mariano Rivera Rivera's still
playing, right? He still comes out.
They play a little enter Sandman. You
know, he doesn't even like that song.
I'll fucking funny. Is it? Huh? Um, Bill,
it's actually not funny.
Kind of like the last three
minutes of this fucking
podcast. Oh, right. All right.
All right, let's, let's, uh, let's
move on with some subjects here.
Do I have anything? How
about we talk about, um,
just talk about Randy Moss
getting fucking traded
by the Goddamn patriots. This is, um,
I dunno what the fuck I was like,
she's going to say there,
I'm looking at like 15 different things
right now. People. That's what I need.
I need to regroup. All
right. First of all,
he had a weird weekend football cause
this week my team had a by, you know,
and it's just such like a fucking,
I don't know,
it's the weirdest guide is like
that Phantom Limb Syndrome.
You're reaching for it and it's
just not fucking there. You know?
I like when you go to a mall and you
can't remember where the fuck you parked.
He just spend enough God
damn hour just searching,
riding around in a golf cart
with that fucking security guard.
Presti alarm key. Pressy lumpy.
You'd think I'm not doing that.
You think I'm not doing
that? Um, so anyways, yeah,
the Patriots Traded Randy Moss,
so I got a bunch of emails from the
happy jet fans and they're sitting there
going like this.
What are they fucking morons with the
fuck would you fucking build fucking
fucking net for?
And I think it's the obvious.
I think he was a, I think he was being
a problem in the fucking locker room.
Why else would you trade him?
Why would you trade Randy Moss
for a fucking third round pick?
Why would you do that?
What level of account would you have
to be in order to make that happen?
I know what a lot of people are gonna say.
Well the Patriots,
you say we never had a
fucking problem with it.
What do you think they're going to say?
They're trying to get that out
of their fucking locker room.
So I actually haven't had this big back
and forth with this dude cause I was
trying to talk to him about like he was
trying to tell me how fucking dumb it
was that the Patriots traded that
guy. And I'm just, it's just like,
haven't you seen tos?
Haven't you seen Stephon Marbury is,
you haven't seen these guys. They've
got all the talent in the fucking world,
but they don't,
they're,
they're not even focused on
whether they're winning or losing.
They're just looking at their fucking
stats. And when half time comes around,
if they don't have their fucking 15
points already or they're five fucking
catchers or somebody else
has more catches in them,
they start acting cunty
which affects the mood in,
in, in the, in the goddamn locker room.
So I was talking to sue about team
chemistry fucking intangibles,
which he thought was ridiculous.
He's like,
are you one of these people who talks
about intangibles? It doesn't matter.
It's all about what you
do on the fucking field.
Really intangibles was the reason why
I knew Peyton manning wasn't as good as
Tom Brady when it really came down to it,
because that guy is far as dropping back,
throwing a ball,
making a completion, has
it all over. Tom Brady.
He's at least 30% better
in all of those categories.
His stats are as leads 30% better,
but the fucking intangible is what goes
on between your fucking ears when the
pressure is on and all of a
sudden it fucking counts in.
The whole season's on the line.
What do you do?
Do you drive your team down for a score
or do you throw a fucking pick six?
Do you lead your team to victory or do
you lose to the eight and eight chargers?
If you're frustrated,
do you fucking hold it in and turn it
into something positive and lead your team
or do you openly show it?
Like I saw him do again yesterday
against the Kansas City chiefs.
He had Peyton face. Oh, I can't
get the ball where I work.
Yeah, why don't you a bitch again
and get a new fucking rule chain.
So Kansas City can't play
fucking defense on you.
Did you guys notice Kansas City has
Romeo, Carmel, and Charlie Weiss.
They basically have our
offensive and defensive
coordinator from back in the day.
Smart sons of bitches over there.
And they were doing the exact same
shit that the patriots used to do.
They just didn't have the personnel
to do it for 60 fucking minutes.
And Peyton had the exact same fucking
look on his face that he had from o two o
three Oh four when he couldn't
beat the fucking patriots.
That sir is what I'm talking about.
That's why people say Derek Jeter is
better than a rod despite a rods fucking
stats. I'm telling you,
Derek Jeter, I would, I,
you can build a team around that.
Can't build a team around fucking a rod.
You know, they're in the moment
when he's supposed to be getting,
you know he's supposed to,
you know,
you don't have three game fucking losing
streak and you need the captain to step
up. You know, say something.
Get the guys go and ea rods over in
the corner putting fucking lip balm on.
It's not a Goddamn leader.
He's over there staring at
himself in the fucking mirror.
I don't know the fuck are
you going to say no, look,
this is what this how I look at it.
If you trade a guy is good as Randy Moss
for a third round pick out of fucking
nowhere, he did something so conti
that they just said, you know what,
it's like the lock,
the door test in a Bronx tale.
He did something and this was
just the tip of the iceberg.
We're fucking out and you
know, didn't, you know, deepen
your heart, Patriot's fan.
Didn't you know that? Eventually it,
does it ever end good with Randy.
Has he ended well with any team member?
With the Vikings?
Yeah. I take a few plays off, you know,
goes out to Oakland cause they're
like, oh, this guy's a headcase.
We always take on head cases and then
all of a sudden they become good guys.
He for fucking problem there. And
he did the same thing out here. So,
so what are you going to do
the fuck you going to do?
What do you think the Patriots were going
to win it? Every scene. Our defense,
even though we beat the fucking dolphins,
didn't we looked like we were in a
prevent defense from the fucking first
quarter on. So, um, I dunno,
I'm not that fucking freaked out about
it considering when I look at the
receivers that we had
when we won super bowls,
we didn't have a Jerry Rice level.
Okay.
Unless you think David Patton
was that guy. I, man, I
don't fucking know. Whatever.
We have a goddamn system.
You have to, bottom line is,
is Randy's a fucking headcase and
the Patriots are an arrogant miserly
franchise. Okay. So we don't
tolerate looking at, we like,
I, the Patriots don't fucking tolerate you
being a cut in the locker room. And, uh,
I think he was done the second he had
that stupid fucking press conference
saying,
I think there's people here in New England
that don't want to see me do well out
Jesus Christ.
Go take your fucking Goddamn
tampons and go to fucking Minnesota.
And you know what he's going to do out
there tonight? You think? I don't know.
He's not going to get 180
fucking yards tonight.
He's going to do exactly what Manny
did when he went to the Dodgers.
He's going to try for like fucking six
weeks because he wants to PR, you know,
show everybody.
He's not the guy that he fucking is,
but eventually that'll all go south.
You know Jesus.
What a cluster fuck tonight
is, Huh? Randy Moss is in town.
You got Rex Ryan, you've talked
to all that shit. And uh,
Brett Farve showed everybody his dick.
I know what a lot of you
will probably thinking.
How fucking stupid do you have to
be this day and age to be famous?
Take a picture of your unit and
fucking send it to somebody.
How fucking dumb do you have to be?
I'm telling you right now.
You're looking at it the wrong way.
All right?
What you really have to see is the
level of ass that you get when you play
quarterback for football team.
What you see in Brett Farve
because my first thing was like
when he did that, I was just like,
well why didn't he just fucking
verbally closed the deal?
Why don't you just go up, talk
some shit, make her laugh,
get her fucking number and then
go out with her. I'm Brett Farve.
I like wrangler jeans. You want
to see my Dick? I mean like what?
What kind of fucking game?
And then I mean it was like this guy has
no fucking game with women because he
never had to.
He's Jesus like the classic.
All American fucking Dudley do right
face and he's the quarterback of the team
probably from junior high on
chicks would just up to him.
Oh my God. Bread. I got
it. God is that farm bread.
How did you do that?
Thank you. Thank you. Won't see my
deck. Where's he from? Mississippi.
You can do that still in Mississippi.
You can walk down the street with your
Dick hanging out of your overalls.
No one gives a shit. Yeah.
More to Dick hanging out. Shit,
you want to go fishing?
They don't give a shit
this whole fucking career. He's been the
fucking man. And when you're the man,
the fucking who is,
don't give a shit.
They take, they take fucking
stampede. You. I bet that,
I bet that that was his game.
Just like fucking Ben Roethlisberger.
I'm starting to think that that
guy wasn't a goddamn sex offender.
I just think he's been the quarterback.
He's been the man, so he has no game.
So he just walks into a bar and he's
like tits and he just reaches over and
grabs them.
Okay.
So, uh, I don't think that those guys
are morons. I look at them the same way.
When people look at someone who
grew up in the inner city, you know,
and they didn't have
access to, to the, to the,
to the good books in their
school was a fucking war zone.
And if you stuck anybody in there,
they also would come out and would
it be at a fucking, you know,
seventh grade reading level,
right?
The same way with me or anybody else.
If I was the fucking man,
if I was the quarterback from
fucking junior high on, oh,
I'd be hanging out at Hooters,
just grab and titties.
Oh you want to see mine
dick?
I loved that he did that.
I love that he did that.
You know,
cause you see him do all that shit
on TV and you're like, Jesus Christ,
I couldn't hit a golf ball as far as
that guy can throw a fucking football.
What happened to me genetically?
What the fuck is wrong with me?
And then Brett Farve does something like
daddy takes a picture of his Dick and
then sends it to somebody and
it's just like a, I dunno,
you know, it's just, there's something,
uh, it's just fucking hilarious.
So evidently they going to do these
stupid pink uniforms for the rest of the,
I mean, how are you not aware of, of
breast cancer at this point? You know,
Goddamn Nfl, don't you have
enough fans? Yeah, we'll, we'll,
we'll even appeal to fucking women
with breast cancer show that we care.
You know, it's a fucking, you know what
saying? I know that sounds fucking mean,
but I'm telling you that was
how that decision was made.
And I know because I
wasn't in the meeting,
I just lump all corporations into the
same shit bag. That's what I do. Um,
all right. Here's a guy actually says a
underrated overrated this week. He said,
uh, he, and he's talking about
the Shit Shit. He was saying, um,
over rate of breast cancer is a terrible
thing, but why does it take precedent?
Oh,
uh,
over all other forms of cancer to the
point where everyone in the NFL has to
spend a month of October looking
like they're in the heart foundation,
all for the sake of breast cancer
awareness. Who isn't aware?
It's the number one killer of
women were told apparently though,
it's actually number seven behind six
under six other things that men also die
of. Oh, that's interesting.
So I guess they mean it's the number
one killer of women only. I don't know.
Granted, men do in rare cases
also get breast cancer, but uh,
it's clearly not about them.
I don't think anyone could get,
go to go through a benefit for a man
with breast cancer without giggling a
little. Uh, what's the number one
killer of men? I have no idea.
No one does prostate cancer.
September is prostate,
prostate cancer awareness month,
which I didn't know until I googled it.
Prostate cancer needs the breast
cancer PR team, uh, colon cancer,
they get a brown ribbon to quote my
friend Nate, can you think of a more,
I don't give a shit color than Brown.
So there you go. Yeah. You know,
I thought it was cool last year that
they did it, but it's like every year,
are they going to be wearing pink?
You know,
I just, you know, with the fucking,
every given he's got a goddamn ribbon.
You know what's funny is when they did
it last year, it actually had effect,
you know, where I was just like, oh,
what the, what the fuck are they wearing?
Pink for Oh, breast cancer
awareness. And then, then it's over,
then it's over and now you're making
jaws two and no one gives a shit, right?
Spielberg isn't directing. It's over.
It's over. We got it. We're aware.
We are aware of, all right.
Overrated. Uh, the Foa,
Harris fohawk style.
The only reason it's overrated
is because you don't,
you don't have a segment on
your podcast called fucking gay.
If you want a Mohawk, that's cool.
Just man up and do it the right way.
So there you go. There you go. I
got to MIT guys. You know what?
For the last 10 minutes, I felt like I
had absolutely nothing to talk about.
I know what's going on in my life.
I'm thinking about buying a fucking house.
Let's talk about my life for a second.
I'm thinking about buying
a fucking house out here.
And I live in a bankrupt state in a city
that technically has no water supply
and they want about 1.2 to one point $4
million for anything remotely fucking
decent out here. And uh, um, I,
I can't do it. I'm not,
do you know what? Fuck it.
I'm not going to be one point
something million dollars in debt.
I'll be on the road for the
rest of my fucking life.
So I've been going on the Internet
and I've been looking at places,
um,
in the middle of nowhere,
and I've been trying to figure out how
I can live in the middle of fucking
nowhere without a losing my mind and be
somehow still existing in this business.
And I realize I can't fucking do it.
You know
how many movie stars
live in Fucking Wyoming?
I know they got ranches out there,
but they wait til they're fucking
famous before they go out to Anna.
What the fuck I'm going to do?
God dammit.
I'm a typical fucking American.
You know what you think I want some
little ass fucking house. I don't.
I want to fuck and spread.
I want a big ass God damn house.
I want a fucking pool inside and outside.
I want a god damn.
I know what I want and it's going
to be fucking ridiculous. But,
uh, you know what's funny is you, if, if,
whatever your job is, if it doesn't
involve you having to be there,
like these people who work
from home on their computers,
you can actually have an
MTV cribs level house.
You just have to live in like fucking,
you know,
the upper east corner of Montana.
You know,
granted you're going to get
attacked by a fucking bobcat.
Every time he'd go out to try
to fucking grill a hot dog.
Ah, fuck. Yeah. What the
fuck you going to do?
You guys wanted some youtube
videos for the week, do yet? Well,
I don't give a shit if you don't because
here they come. All right. Youtube, uh,
and our l gets knocked out.
Um,
this is a referee getting
knocked out and a,
I think it's rugby and you got to see
this because the guy who knocks out
inadvertently knocks out the referee
might be one of the most unathletic I on
athletic guys I've ever seen in my life.
He looks like some guy in times square
who's trying to charge you too much for a
fucking digital camera and
he's got a fat round face.
If he had any sort of athletic ability,
he would have been able to jump over the
ref instead of kneeing him in the back
of the fucking,
well,
I got to tell you something.
This unathletic Douche bag,
he knocks this ref the fuck out.
Like I'm surprised this guy didn't die.
This fucking pudgy jackass is running
full speed and it's the most pathetic
attempt to hurdle.
This guy couldn't hurdle of fucking
tube sock and he's trying to hurt his
fucking get it and they just, Ah,
you know, when you know,
you know, you know the,
the form you have when your hurdle one
legs outstretched and the other one's
bent, it's the bent knee and he's got
all that fucking pudgy wait, come in.
And he just fucking knees and right in
the back of the head and that guy just
goes limp. Um, all right,
this is one,
this one is actually funny and scary
is called a Turkish guy goes bananas.
And,
uh,
I believe he screams a lot and he
looks like he attempts to do that.
You ever see those people?
Uh,
like the break dancers or whatever the
fuck they are or dancers in general.
And they do that thing where they
jump up in the air like sideways,
like a deer and sort
of do like a three 60,
they'll almost like parallel to the
ground and then they somehow land and they
jump up and they do it again.
This guy is basically doing that
but he's too fat and out of shape.
So he's just sort of,
he's just sort of rolling
around on the ground,
but he gets his legs and his arms
out. It's a pretty, uh, he's very, uh,
sorta Belushi ask where he's Pudgy,
but he's very light on his feet. Um,
is another great one.
This is about as rock and roll as it gets.
Swedish singer vomits during performance.
It's just phenomenal.
The type of music he's singing,
the fact that he doesn't stop the,
he's singing like that death metal,
like order draw Bra.
And then occasionally he'd
be like [inaudible] and then
he actually is puking as
he's going. That's awesome.
Um, loud car, horn prank.
These are all things that you can
search or you can also also go to the
[inaudible] podcast.com and we'll
have all of these, the official,
the MM podcast.com,
the official fan webpage on the Monday
morning podcast that is no longer on
iTunes. Okay. I don't know
what else I'm supposed to do.
We've called these people,
we've emailed them,
they have not gotten back
to us and they're probably,
I'm going to get served some sort of
papers for stocking at this point.
Cause that's what I feel like.
I feel like it was a girl that I went out.
I had a good time. Evidently
she didn't. And um,
you know, I went through the
whole roommate lying to me phase,
you know. Hello? Yeah. Hey,
it's bill. Is iTunes there?
I yeah. No. Um,
I tunes in the shower. Oh yeah.
Dina, do you know when, when,
when they're going to be
out? Oh, I dunno. It's
29 minutes. Why did I say 20? Fuck. Yeah.
29 minutes. Okay. Fucking half hour later.
Hey, age, let's bill.
He's I tubes there. Um,
yeah, no, they're still in the shower
but doing that for fucking
two weeks and uh, you know,
it's that classic classic fucking
corporate shit where they have themselves
completely insulated. We'll get back
to you if we fucking feel like it.
Itunes, we own the tunes. Fucking cons.
Do you know, I saw, I think, um, when
I was listening on am radio. Dot. Even,
did I already talk about this or
did I start to talk about this?
They were talking about online
banking. Okay. The Shit.
Remember back in the day when
I was talking about that going,
you have to be out of your fucking mind
to pay bills or to do any sort of online
banking because someone's going to steal
your identity and take all the money
out of your bank account. Well, guess
what? That's exactly what's happening.
All these morons who sent me emails going,
dude,
I don't even have to go to
the post office. I don't
have to lick a fucking stamp.
It's so fucking easy.
That's what I love about computers.
Everything so fucking easy.
And then you get raped in the ass
and then they then, then no one ever
addresses it is that goes, hey, maybe,
maybe back in the day it
was a little bit better.
Like people sitting there going,
uh,
they were talking about when I
was bitching about that going,
I don't pay bills online.
I'm not having all that information
online for any fucker in the world who has
an ability to hack into
shit to come after my stuff.
I just don't want that to happen. And
then these fucking morons are going, well,
what about the guy down the post office?
Like,
that guy has access to the entire
fucking world down the post office.
Even though he does
have access to my shit.
There's actually cameras on those
people. And Yeah, he might get me,
but they're going to get him.
They get those guys and those guys go
to fucking jail as opposed to someone on
the Internet who can look at everybody
shit once they break into it.
So evidently they're saying that if
you are dumb enough to bank online that
they're saying don't use
the same computer that uh,
that you bank with tea
to do like email with.
Cause evidently that's how they get in.
I have no idea.
But someone told me awhile ago that
all my information is already up on the
fucking Internet anyways
because my country bank put
it up there just in case I
want to, I want to bank
online. It's like, no,
it's not just in case it's cause you're
phasing out fucking cash and this is the
direction you've taken my money.
I don't know man. I have a real like got
a real fucking problem with banks. Egg.
What's, what are you laughing at?
Nia is here. Everybody come on in.
I this has just been a
real negative podcasts.
Come over here. You just had
a what? I just had a great
conversation with so many,
so, oh yeah. Did they
tell you that you know,
you needed to make anything a
priority? No, they didn't. Okay.
Who were you talking to?
Talking to her and an actress and she
was just positive and awesome and it was
great. I know you're doing, you're
fine. Can I ask you a question?
Why are you with me? Why am I,
yeah, why are you fucking with me?
I'm fucking like this
curmudgeonly old man.
I'm sitting here going off
on online banking and I
realize I got halfway through
it that I really didn't have enough facts
and am radio one the other day and I
felt like I knew something. Yeah. I don't
know. Why am I with you? I love you.
Jesus. Get out of here. Wow. Huh?
Well it's supposed to be funny.
Yes. It's supposed to be funny.
Oh, okay. So I'm supposed to say something
clever. I think the moment passed.
I think the moment past, the moment
passed. All right, well that's great.
You had a nice positive [inaudible]
going to do now. Eat something healthy.
Okay.
Say a load of the bobcat's.
Uh, she hates me right now. The,
I thought you were going to
come over and trashed me.
That's your job on the podcast and I
supposed to come over and tell me you love
me. All right. You know something.
This podcast started
out with such promise,
kind of like Randy Moss.
You know we went 16 at, Oh,
here we go.
We're going to fucking undefeated season.
Oh fuck 18 and one. Well, whatever.
There's next year. Tom Brady
gets his knee blown out. Fuck.
All right, Tom Brady's coming back. We
get raped by the fucking ravens. Wait,
this is actually a patriots thing.
I'm starting off with Randy Moss and
then Randy starts fucking pouty with his
itchy God damn beard.
What a fucking moron.
You know, who knows? Maybe he'll become
a great analyst like he Shawn Johnson.
Keyshawn Johnson was the greatest one I
ever saw where Tampa Bay just sent him
home. They didn't even try to get anything
for him. They were just like, yeah.
Keyshawn why don't you just
leave? Just fucking, just go home.
What like for the rest of the
day now for good. Just just go.
Then I saw him later on that night on
ESPN and he was wearing like a USC Jersey
and he completely could give a fuck and a,
it was just,
you know, but then turned out to
be a great analyst. All right,
let's continue with the Youtube
Shit. A loud car. Horn prank.
A woman's segway crash is a great one.
If you always wanted to punch your woman
but didn't want to go to jail for it,
you can at least watch one. Basically
Punch herself with the floor of a hotel.
Um, and gay hipster fight. That's
a great one. Gay hipster fight.
Evidently that's a got a ton of hits.
Uh, let's get back to the fucking,
let's just try and go with some topics
and maybe I can pull myself out of the
mud here.
Um,
this was called Dick at work bill.
I work with a hoarder on top of that.
Uh,
the dude seems to pride himself on saying
deuce chilling stuff that makes your
head shake.
He's also one of those guys that throws
everyone else under the bus when he's
called out by the manager for his mess.
Example of Douche chilling sayings.
The first day,
the first day we were
in our current office,
he walks up to a group of us
and sees that we're doing the,
getting to know you banter.
He opens up with a,
suppose it's story from his frat days
that ended up with him naked with,
with a Manet's jar.
Okay.
Jesus Christ example I like of this guy
is just really very efficient example of
under the bus throwing.
Yeah.
Commencing example of under, under the
bus throwing. All right. Here we go.
When he was told why he has so much stuff.
MMM.
When he was told why he has so much stuff,
he pointed out my friends cubicle. Oh.
When he was asked, do you mean when he
was asked why? There's so much stuff,
I guess in his work area.
He pointed out my friends cubicle
that had a bunch of Batman stuff,
tastefully decorating the desk and wall.
Someone else had Mickey mouse
stuff, uh, in the same way,
which he dismissed as Disneyland.
Always one of those guys.
He's like Coby Bryan.
Well, Shaq rapes girls too.
Remember that fucking cunt.
MMM.
To, first of all, can we get
to your friends who have, uh,
I can see if a female has Mickey
mouse stuff. You know what I mean?
That's always creepy, isn't
it? You know that the,
the girl whose adult fully developed,
gone through puberty and actually has a
car payment and still act like they're
fucking eight years old. And uh, I
always thought that that was creepy.
You go and you go to hook up with them
and they have stuffed animals on their
baby, a Wookiee pokey,
right. And there was just,
you felt like a fucking pedophile.
So listen to this,
last week I did love line with a d um,
psycho Mike and Dr drew.
I had a great time on the show and uh,
I was absolutely fucking blown away.
Bye.
Just the advice Dr drew gives and how he
gets right to the root of the problem.
And then like his Hannibal Lecter ability,
remember the,
remember the fucking silence of the lambs
where he would just look at somebody's
shoes and could tell what the fuck
happened to them when they were like 11.
Like doctor drew was doing that shit.
Like some girl called up, ah fuck it.
I might as well tell the story. She
calls up and they're like, yeah,
you're on love line. You know what's
going on? And then she just say,
yeah,
it really hurts it like,
like really alien heads
and right off the bat he goes,
what happened to you when you were six?
And basically figured out that right
around that she didn't admit it.
She asked if she had ever been touched.
Hurry,
I'm laughing at fucking being molested.
I'm not laughing at this shit.
I was just blown away. He asked
her, he said no, and she's like,
I like tags. But my, my cousin Rick had
said I hadn't gotten a trial and funding
and asked him. I was like, how the
fuck did you do that? And it goes,
when I heard her, I heard a six
year old, the way she talked,
I heard a fucking six year
old. And sometimes when
that shit happens, you know,
it's so overwhelming that
they just arrested development
or something is what he
said.
So having seen that,
I mean maybe I'm now the, you know,
typical moron. That's what I do.
I stand next to a smart guy for 30
seconds and then try to rephrase what the
fuck he just said.
And I tried to appear smart myself,
but now there's a whole new level
of being creeped out when you know,
you see girls like that and uh,
yeah,
that was always the vibe I felt like,
can you feel like, you know those you go,
you go into their fucking bedroom and
it's like a little girl's room and it's
like, can you get that
fucking stuff off of your bed?
Like the whole thing is like
pink. I mean, I dunno if I,
if I'm just fucking,
you know,
just connecting dots now that
don't even fucking exist.
But now I'm looking back and all these
fucking, all these horrors that you see,
uh, on those, the, that, that,
that fucking old guy to playboy
mansion who have those state,
they walk around with that,
those stupid fucking high
heels with the Fuzzy Pink Shit.
The fur on it talking like they're,
they're little girls
does. Is that what that means? Ah, it's
just, it's, it's fucking beyond creepy.
Okay. So at this point, because
of that little moment on Loveline,
if I saw somebody and they had like a
bunch of Mickey Mouse Shit, I would,
I would first figure out if,
if I don't, I don't know,
like what's with the Batman
thing? Yeah. What's with that guy
as all this Batman stuff?
Did he get fucking diddled when he was
reading a comic book when he was nine?
So now he has this arrested development
that now he's actually fucking at work
any sitting in there doing this
adult job. Wow. But in his head,
just trying to block out the trauma
that happened in his head. He just has
Dan Nnn, nnn, nnn, nnn.
Just playing on a loop.
Non fucking Stop Batman.
You know, there's man in there, Batman,
Batman. That's just fucking weird
to me. Do I have anything like that?
I don't. Oh, there goes that fucking
theory. All right. Plowing ahead.
Um,
as to the hoarding,
his work area is ridiculous and
something of a tourist highlight.
And when anyone visits are, uh, are
off something of a tourist highlight.
When anyone visits our office,
we work in a, in a four man.
We work in four main areas and sets.
No one wants to sit with them.
He's taking the initiative to expand
his rubbish empire over the entire area.
The dude has a problem since our last
supervised advisor tried to make an
example of him by banishing him to the Er,
to a work site with no desks and
just the locker. Lo and behold,
word got back to us that he started
a new nest of garbage by the lockers.
Why don't they just fire this
guy? Yeah, I dunno. Whatever.
It just keeps going on and on with this
fucking guy and he's got damn trash.
You know what? This reminds you
guys of a haze. Anybody at work?
I used to work in this
warehouse and we were,
we were a bunch of fucking maniacs and
all day long, all we did was break balls.
Um,
I've told you this shit before because
we were basically mentally smart enough
to work in a warehouse by the time you
went third grade, you know what I mean?
Supposed to be 10 boxes according to the
packing list. One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, 10.
There you go. One, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, eight,
nine, 10, 11, 12. Sorry,
sesame street, flashback. Um,
yeah.
So we used to fuck around all the time
and our manager had no control over us.
You know, we didn't respect him.
We knew he wasn't going to in fire.
We wasn't going to fire us.
He didn't have the goddamn heart.
And at the end of the day
we got a fucking job done.
So he decides that were the problem is,
is that we're all too fucking young.
There's a level of immaturity out there.
Cause we were all in our early twenties
that we, uh, that he should hire.
He hired this 38 year old guy.
MMM.
I actually remember his name, but I'm not
gonna, I don't name names on this shit.
And, uh, Jesus Christ, that
fucking guys almost 60,
he was like 38 and that was
22 fucking years ago. He's 60.
What the fuck?
So anyways,
this guy drove a fucking sky blue
Chevy cavalier stationwagon four door
barebones factory fucking rims.
The car was like three years old.
He had 8,000 miles on it.
All right?
And this guy was a Weirdo and
he had these fucking glasses,
these black frame glasses
that nobody wore in the 80s.
So we immediately started
calling him woody. We'd be, Hey,
what are you, uh, how many boxes we get
over there? And this guy was just bizarre.
And he'd come over, why call me woody?
Oh, you're trying to bring me down.
So he kept saying,
you're trying to bring me down.
Did I already tell this fucking story?
This sounds oddly familiar to me.
So we would just fuck with them.
We would just be like, okay,
at four 31 today, everybody just
stopped going. What do you, what do you,
what do you, what are you in?
That's what we would do. He would be
picking orders down in the,
in the warehouse area and we would
all be picking orders with them.
And then out of nowhere
we would just start going, where do you,
what do you, what do you, what do you,
what do you, what do, what
do you, what are you doing
top of our fucking lungs.
I know it's fucking am as sophomores,
but it would find, and what,
we wouldn't say it to him,
we were just fucking be sick was really
passive aggressive cause he already
talked to management about us calling
him woody. So it's like, dude,
we're not calling you woody.
We're just going on
woody, woody, woody, woody, woody,
look in your vicinity. So we do the same
thing. You're trying to bring me down.
You're trying to bring me down.
So eventually we haze this guy so
much that he fucking quit, right?
He and his little Chevy Cavalier fucking
four door sky blue bare bone station
wagon drove right out. And the back
of my head, I was like, you know what,
I've got a bad feeling that mother
fuckers coming back is right,
right around the time when people
first started going postal.
So it wasn't enough that that we
actually drove this guy out of work.
What are they fucking maniacs I worked
with somehow got the guys home phone
number and the following week he still
didn't have a job and he picked up the
phone. He's like, hello.
And there was 10 of us standing
around the phone and we all go,
what do you, what do
you, what do you want?
And I always pictured him slamming the
phone down and then looking up like that
dude in a clockwork orange
when he realizes the dude
who came and fucking kick
the shit out of him and
raped his wife came back. Um,
that's kind of an ugly story,
isn't it?
Yeah.
You know, for, you know,
for as much as people sit there and they
talk about this cyber bullying and all
this type of shit and how
fucking horrible it is,
which it is obviously a,
you know,
I don't like how everybody tries
to act like they were a victim.
Well, I mean weren't you a little bit of
both? Cause I know I used to get bullied.
Jesus Christ walking up the street
looking like fucking that kid on the, uh,
the f family Griffith.
What the fuck is that?
The honey Andy Griffith. How did
I come up with a family? Griffith.
Ah, my fucking brain is
mush. Um, yeah, people,
you immediately came walking up
the street. My fucking might,
my hair was orange when I was growing up.
I think I didn't get the shit kicked
out of me. Yup. But then, you know,
I got a little bit bigger.
I've got a couple more freckles.
I got got some more confidence and I
just started picking on kids who were
younger than I was.
So now whenever I see
those goddamn stories,
mmm. I, I just, I dunno,
I, I see both sides of it.
I just see like, yeah, you
shouldn't have fucking done that,
but I don't judge the bully
because I did shit like that.
Now you guys didn't do shit like that.
Eh? Go fuck yourselves. All right.
Why don't you guys, do you know what,
that's the theme of this whole podcast.
Everybody can go fuck themselves.
That can just put me off
in such a goddamn move. A,
you might want to make that a
priority. Okay. Um, anyways,
what do I got coming up this week?
Let's hype my gigs. Shall We?
Let's try to get something
positive going here.
God knows I already have to go
make up with fucking Nia. I get it.
I get that it's a podcast,
but you have to be mean. Yeah.
Um, oh, by the way, let's talk about
something podcast, uh, podcast,
something positive. Uh, my let it go.
DVD was the number one fucking downloaded
comedy album on iTunes this week,
so I want to thank all you guys for
that. Um, I really appreciate it.
Keep buying it.
Keep downloading the son of a bitch.
If you go to bill bird.com I've got a
link right there. You Click right on.
It takes you right to amazon.com all
right. Once again, I told you, man,
it makes a tremendous fucking gifts for
some of you. Don't give a shit about,
watch this.
I'm going to click on this shit right now.
You're probably selling it for fucking
three bucks at this point. What is it?
Down to 10 99 you cheap
cuts 10 99 come on,
come on.
You fuckers
already gave you the oh Jesus
pod a goddamn ringtone. I
made 300 bucks off debt.
You Cheap Fox 99 cents.
That's it. 300 bucks.
You motherfucker. What are you guys saving
up for a happy meal? You tight fucks.
Uh,
you don't.
I always seem to be selling something
that that is just completely obsolete.
I sold a ringtone back when people now
had the technology to make their own
ringtone and now I'm selling a DVD.
Next month I'm going to be
selling and brand new VCR.
Everybody now seriously,
please go out and buy it because
this is the big thing about that.
Just download the fucker
cause I want to tell you,
even if you saw it on comedy central,
you have not seen my standup special yet.
You haven't seen it. Hang on. Hey, let
me call you right back in five minutes.
Um, you have not seen when I say I'm
going to call you back in five minutes,
that means in about an hour and
a half, unless I forget. Um,
you haven't seen my special
yet because it was edited.
They took out two huge chunks of
material. Uh, this is my, I'm telling you,
this is my best work so far.
I really want you to fucking see it and
then buy tickets to my show so I can buy
a big goddamn house and have a pool
inside and outside and then just sit there
and still be sad and depressed and
realize that I need to work on myself.
That's the goal. People,
that is definitely the goal.
So let's hype the gigs I got this week
or coming up in the next week. Um,
I'm going to be at the
Wilbur Theater in Boston,
Massachusetts October 20th and all
proceeds after they're done taxing us in a
pain for the theater are going to go,
uh,
to my brother's campaign who's
running for state senate. Um,
just to let you know. Alright, I
gotta put that out there legally.
That's what you're going there.
That's what you're supporting.
If you don't support his message,
please do not go.
I'm not trying to trick anybody if this
is all on the up and up. All right?
And then after that,
I'm going to be on, um,
October 22nd and we at the
pantageous theater in Minneapolis,
Minnesota on the 23rd. I'm going to be
at the Vic Theater in Chicago, Illinois.
Um,
the following week,
I have one night only at
the bone in Saint Louis,
Missouri on October 30th one night,
only October 30th at the
funny bone in Saint Louis.
And I'm hanging around an extra day
and I'm going to go to the rams.
How about those fucking lions? Huh?
I stayed away from them this week.
Oh, that's what the fuck I was going to
talk about. You know, I did, I did my, uh,
pick my three teams this week again.
All right.
You want to know who the fuck I had?
See if I got it here.
I had Atlanta first
Cleveland given three points.
It's like there's no way the browns are
going to win two weeks in a row and fuck
that man.
Genie,
that Rhett cunt who sat in the Goddamn
getaway car during the bank robbery and
then read it out. The guys in the
bank, that fucking rat bastard. So, uh,
I took Atlanta. I won that game.
Then I had two, four o'clock games.
I had the Tennessee titans getting
seven points. First, the cowboys,
right? It's my buddy Paul verse.
He says, he's told me, he goes,
all Vince young does is win. And I dunno,
Tony Romo just doesn't do it for me.
He just fails at a very high level,
throws for 300 5,400 yards
and they still somehow lose.
Although another one of my buddies
is telling me it's the play calling.
It's not his fault,
but I just felt like a seven
points was a lot of fucking points.
So now I'm 2.0 and I'm like,
Holy Shit,
I got to Goddamn San Diego
chargers getting six points first.
The Oakland Raiders,
I might go three you know,
and actually start
gambling for fucking real.
If I can pick them like this.
This is ridiculous.
So San Diego has the fucking ball.
They're down by one point and they're
Ron like Oakland's 10 yard line and I'm
just sitting there already. Got
My arms in the air. I'm like,
worst case scenario, they kick
a field goal. They miss it.
They're only down by one and Oakland's
just going to run out the clock.
I'm going to win this. I'm getting
six points. Either fucking way.
San Diego kicks the Goddamn Ball.
I'm going to win by eight.
They missed the field goal,
they run it out.
I'll still clear my bed by five
points and this is why I don't gamble.
Fucking Philip Rivers goes back to pass,
brings his arm back.
Some defense events slaps the fucking
ball out of his hand. It's a fumble.
Somebody from the Raiders picks the ball
up and runs like fucking 90 yards for a
touchdown.
And I ended up losing the Goddamn bet.
And I'm gonna tell you right now people
that right there is why I don't gamble.
That's why I don't gamble.
So well let me see if I would
have one even if I teased it.
Cause if you tease it on three teen
tease, don't you get like nine points? Um,
cause I would have wanted my
first week and I still think,
I think I would have won.
Right. Hang on one second.
So they ended up losing by eight points.
Yeah,
I would've won if I teased it.
I still want a fucking one one night.
Don't you get nine points on a three t
and t's I should have fucking done that
man. I would've won two out
of three weeks. All right,
I'm going to start putting
my picks up on the uh,
the m podcast.com so you
guys can follow along.
I might even ask version if we'll,
we'll put both of ours up.
And you can watch right now we're
both five and four for the year. Uh,
so I went to and one this God damn week.
And uh,
as far as the Monday night game tonight,
who do you like?
Who Do you like the jets or the Vikings?
I got to go with the jets.
I just think,
you know Brett Farve still trying
to tuck his goddamn unit away.
But I think Randy Moss,
I dunno,
I dunno. Is Reavis back, is
he back from Reavis island?
Fucking fag.
Randy BB.
Is he going to grab for
his fucking hamstring again
when fucking Randy beats him
again over the top when he has
no help when he's one on one.
That was my favorite player of
the year watching Randy Moss.
Just skipping down the sandy
beaches of fucking Reavis island,
that insecure bastard.
Who would ever come up with that
because you could win because when
you come to Reavis island, there's,
there's no way to get off unless
you have a boat. Oh, okay.
They are reverse. Um, anyways,
I think that that's the podcast
for this week. Uh, please, um,
if you're in the Boston area
and you want to come down, uh,
it helps support my brother's campaign.
That's a big thing.
This is a last second
date that we're adding.
So we're trying to hope we can get as
many people as we humanly possibly can.
Um, get down to the theater. And uh,
for those of you living in Chicago,
there's about 50 tickets left
and same thing in Minneapolis.
So I want to thank everybody ahead of
time for the unbelievable fucking support.
Uh,
isn't actually a hilarious,
I'm playing a theater in Minneapolis next
week and I'm not picking them against
the jets. Um, whatever.
I just want to thank all you guys for
supporting me and my comedy and a,
I'm going to thank the Penn state
Nittany lions for losing this week,
getting their fucking asses kicked because
I'm going to be at the Columbus funny
bone and obviously Columbus,
Ohio on 11th,
November 12th through the 14th and all
the Iowa state buckeyes are playing Penn
state and it's to be announced,
but with their two losses,
I think it'll be in the afternoon.
I think it's official at this point that
they won't be contending for anything.
And uh, I was really nervous that that
game was going to be at eight o'clock,
which would mean that a,
I don't get to go to the game and B,
no one will be at my show because
all be out there going, Oh,
h Oh mother fucker. Um, and that's it.
How about my Boston Bruins?
Huh? You like that shit.
You like that anybody can just fly to
fucking Saint Louis or Dallas and get
their first loss of the year.
It takes a team to fly all the way over
to Prague to get your fucking ass is
kicked to start the year
off. Right. Um, can I be,
explain to me why they keep doing fucking,
uh, American sports over there in,
in Europe.
Like they give a shit,
like they're going to start
buying it up like our genes. Okay.
Like every year the NFL does that
fucking Goddamn game in Wembley Stadium.
I don't, I don't, I guess it sells
out. I Dunno. But if you go over there,
they don't give a fuck.
They were in debt.
They were into soccer or their version
of football. Absolutely. Fuck it.
I don't know. Oh, Jesus. You know,
this is the greatest way to end this
fucking podcast right now with just like,
I came in there, you know what this, this,
this podcast is like march, you know,
in with the, in, in like a lion out like
a lamb. I'm going out like a lamb here.
All right. That's it. Everybody
have a great God damn week.
I hope to see you. Uh,
next Wednesday, October 20th at the
Wilbur Theater in Boston, Massachusetts.
Helped my brother out. Um, and that's it.
God bless all you. I'll talk to you next.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].